معنا من نابلس الباحث بالشان الاسرائيلي
عزام ابو العد سيد عزام الى اي مدى يمكن
الركون الى استطلاعات الراي لفهم هذا
التغير والتحول في المزاج السياسي في
اسرائيل ولماذا يتم تقديم جانس كبديل
محتمل في حال اجريت
انتخابات بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم
ولجمهور مستمعي
ومشاهدي يعني الواقع بان مساله استطلاعات
الراي في دوله الاحتلال هي مساله تاريخيه
وقديمه ومعروفه طبعا تجريها عدد من الصحف
بمساعده مراكز ابحاث وعاده ما تكون
استطلاعات الراي هذه دقيقه كما راينا في
سنوات انتخابيه سابقه ف استطلاعات الراي
هذه يمكن ان يعتمد عليها هذا اولا ثانيا
استطلاعات الراي هذه تنشرها الصحف
الاسرائيليه بين الحين الحين لتحديد
المزاج العام او ان بعض السياسيين يعني من
خلال نفوذه وعلاقته بالصحفيين والصحف
المصنفه سواء على اليمين او اليسار يدفع
باتجاه نشر
اي نتائج استطلاعات الراي اذا كانت مناسبه
له
وفي يعني تدعم موقفه كما يحدث الان مع
بيني جانس حيث الصحف اليساريه باغلب نشرت
هذه الاستطلاعات اما بالنسبه لبنيامين
نتنياهو بنيامين نتنياهو اصبح ينظر اليه
في اسرائيل على انه الفشل مجسدا بنيامين
نتنياهو فشل في منع السابع من اكتوبر يفشل
الان في اعاده الاسرى وقضيه الاسرى تتحول
الى قضيه
مركزيه لها صداه وسيكون لها تداعيات
كبيره جدا موضوع تسريبات الكابينيت ايضا
يحرج هذه الحكومه ويضعف كثيرا من رصيد
بنيامين نتنياهو بحيث ان يعني يروج الان
في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ولا سما
المعاديه له بان الكابينيت الذي يفترض به
ان يناقش مساله مستقبل اسرائيل ووجودها في
اخطر واطول واشرس حرب تخوضها منذ تاسيسها
تحول هذا الكابينيت الى سرك بكل ما تح
الحرب سيد عزام باشار تك طول الحرب
الانتقاد الان لم يعود يسمع فقط لتصريحات
ووعود السياسيين فيما يتعلق باهداف هذه
الحرب الان التشكيك ايضا في الجيش وان كان
يحقق فعلا اهداف هذه الحرب او يحقق فعلا
ما يمكن تسميته انتصارات حقيقيه في هذه
الحرب ماذا عن هذا
البعد اريد ان اشير الى اخطر ظاهره وهي
اول مره تمر فيها اسرائيل بهذه الحاله وهي
التشكيك في الجيش الجيش جيش ينظر اليه في
العقليه الاسرائيليه والعقليه الصهيونيه
انه البوتقه التي يصهر فيها كل المهاجرين
الى دوله الاحتلال ويتحولون الى مواطنين
وهو الدرع وهو الحامي وهو المظله وبالتالي
التشكيك في في الجيش هو تشكيك في جوهر
وجود دوله اسرائيل كمجتمع وظيفي حربي
مقاتل في خدمه الغرب وفي خدمه الاستعمار
الاحلالي وبالتالي هذه اول م يعني اذا
اردنا ان نستعرض تاريخ حروب الاحتلال منذ
العام
1948 حتى يوم الناس هذا ومن ضمن ذلك حرب
73 حرب اكتوبر التي حدث فيها نوع من الفشل
والاختراق لم يحدث ان ادين الجيش او سلطت
اليه اصابع الاتهام لكن بنيامين نتنياهو
الان في سبيل نجاه نجاته الشخصيه اولا ومن
ثم نجاه اليمين الاسرائيلي يقوم ب
بتفتيت اهم لا يعني عمود الخيمه الذي اقيم
عليه مجتمع الاحتلال وهو الجيش يتهم الجيش
الان بالتقصير يتهم الجيش ب بانه لم يعمل
كما يجب في السابع من اكتوبر يتهم الجيش
بانه لم يتعامل بجديه مع تهديدات حماس
والاخطر من ذلك بانه في مجموعات المجموعات
اليمينيه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يتم
الترويج لنظر بشكل منظم وهي بان الجيش
الذي عموده الفقري من اليساريين كان يعلم
باحداث السابع من اكتوبر وسهل احداث
السابع من اكتوبر لكي يطيح بهذه الحكومه
لكن الامور خرجت عن السيطره من يد الجيش
هناك الكثير من نظريات المؤامره التي تتهم
الجيش ومصدرها اليمين الاسرائيلي وتحديدا
بنيامين نتنياهو وبالتالي هذه المساله
مساله اتهام الجيش يكون لها ما بعدها
ولاول مره في تاريخ دوله
الاحتلال يهان قائد الاركان بهذا الشكل
يعني ربما نعم ايضا هناك دعوات تتكرر
لبيني جانس ان ينسحب من مجلس الحرب ما
حساباته التي تبقيه حتى الان ضمن هذا
المجلس مع كل ما يوجه من انتقادات
لنتنياهو بانه يستبقي هذه الحرب ويقوم كل
ما يقوم به من اجل حساب حاته الخاصه اي
نتنياهو الان حسابات بني جانس متعدده اولا
يريد ان يظهر بمظهر المنقذ للدوله والرجل
رجل المعارضه المسؤول والجنرال السابق
الذي يعني بني جانس هو قائد هيئه اركان
سابق الذي ارائه يعني تساعد وتدفع بهذه
الحرب نحو الانتصار هذا اولا ثانيا كانت
حساباته بانه
يريد ان يكون او ان يظهر امام الشارع
الاسرائيلي بانه الشخص العاقل في مستشفى
مجانين وهذا بالضبط ما اراده بيني جانس في
خطابه الاخير بيني جانس في خطابه الاخير
عندما يعني تحدث عن الكابينيت والتسريبات
وقال بان هذا الكابينيت الذي يفترض به ان
يكون اعلى
هيئه تناقش امور الحرب الاستراتيجيه ينشغل
بصغائر الامور وسف سفها ين قائد هيئه
الاركان وهذا غير مقبول اذا الصوره التي
يريدها هي ان يظهر بمظهر العاقل بمظهر
القائد بمظهر الشخص الحكيم في مستشفى من
المجانين يسمى الكابينت
الاسرائيلي من نابلس الباحث بالشان
الاسرائيلي عزام ابو العدس شكرا جزيلا
لك